[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM FRANK: Thank you very much
for giving me the opportunity
to talk with you guys today.
So yeah, I'm a computational
astrophysicist.
So my day job is not
thinking about aliens.
That's kind of my night job.
So my day job is studying
things like how stars form
and how planets evaporate.
I do magneto fluid--
large-scale
supercomputer magneto
fluid dynamical simulations
of astrophysical gas dynamics.
But because I do a lot
of work with the public,
I've ended up having to think
a lot about climate change,
because I write
about climate change.
And over the years,
I've have had
to deal with a lot
of climate denial.
And that is unbelievably
frustrating.
And in doing that,
I came to start
thinking about the problem
differently about how--
ways of-- the ways in
which we frame climate
change entirely wrong.
And so that's really
what the topic of my book
is, so "Light of the
Stars Alien Worlds
and the Fate of the Earth."
So what I want to
take you through
is kind of a
different perspective
on thinking about
climate change from what
I would call the
astrobiological perspective.
So the idea here is you
can't solve a problem
until you understand it.
And you can't understand it
until you can tell its story.
And my premise here
is that the story
we're telling about climate
change is the wrong story.
And it's not our fault.
It's just that we're in
a different position now.
And we can tell a
different story.
And the story we're trying to
tell about is the human future.
What is the human future on
a climate changing planet?
But in some sense
really what I'm asking
you is what is the future
for any civilization,
a large-scale industrial
civilization on any planet.
I am going to take you through
why that's not a crazy question
to ask.
So the problem we know
is climate change, right,
that the anthropogenically
driven change in the planetary
state that we are switching
from a state for the last 10,000
years that's been
basically warm and moist,
meaning most of
the stuff isn't--
most of it or not most--
but lots of the water
isn't locked up in
ice to something
that we don't know, right?
We're pushing the
Earth into a new state.
And then there's
also coupled to this
are issues of resource depletion
from fresh water to forests.
So this issue of
sustainability comes up, right?
Can we build a sustainable
version of our planet?
And when we think about
science and politics,
right, because that
somehow whenever
we wanted to have
this conversation,
it immediately falls into
the political domain.
And while certainly
policy is a pol--
there's going to be politics--
the science itself is what gets
cast--
suddenly becomes political.
And when you think about
this, it's really amazing.
And when I did the research
for this book, I realized that,
or I found that actually
a president in 1965
gave a speech to Congress
identifying CO2 and climate
change as a potential
problem, right?
So the idea that somehow this
is this modern hoax that climate
denialists want to
tell you about is--
this gives lie to it, that in
1965 actually that should be
President Johnson gave a
speech before Congress where he
mentioned CO2 as--
and the climate change--
as a particular problem.
But so we know
what's happening now
is this political polarization--
that somehow this science issue
got lumped into all the
other kinds of polarization
that we have.
So if you have a certain set
of beliefs, for some reason
you also have to think
that climate change is
a hoax or climate
change isn't happening.
And that's part
of the dilemma we
face in trying to take
any action on the problem.
So what is the real problem?
What is the real problem
that we're facing?
And it's really one of
perspective, not politics,
because the science has been
settled for a long time.
My first job after
undergraduate--
I took a year and a half off.
And I did lots of crazy
things like planted trees
in British Columbia.
I was a bouncer at the
Rocky Horror Picture Show
on the 8th Street
Playhouse in New York.
But I also got a job in 1985 at
Jim Hansen's Goddard Institute
for Space Studies.
And I asked them--
I was a programmer basically
assigned to the program.
And I said, what
are we doing here?
And they said, oh,
you know, we're
studying to see whether
or not the climate is
going to be changing.
That's an idea we have.
And I was like, whoa, right?
So this was 1985 long before
anybody else had heard of it.
By 1988 Hansen gives that
very famous testimony
in front of Congress
saying, like, look,
we actually have
found the signal.
So the science is old.
And so the science
is not the problem.
It's the perspective
that's the problem.
And our perspective-- and I
think the reason that we have
such a hard time--
the public-- and I deal a
lot with the public through
my science writing--
is that we think it's
a one-time story.
We think we are a
one-time story, right?
We think climate change is
something happening to us.
And that's the only
time it's ever happened.
And there's no guides,
no examples, no other--
no way of framing this that
allows us to see something
deeper in it.
So all we end up doing
is fighting about
whether it's happening or not.
So what I'm going
to argue in the book
is that we have to broaden the
perspective to truly understand
what is truly happening.
That's the basic idea here.
So what I mean by
that is we must
learn to think like a planet.
And that is something
that over our history--
our 10,000 year history
of civilization--
we've never been called
upon to do it before.
And by civilization what I mean
is agriculture, city building,
right?
Clearly human beings have been
around for longer than that.
But it's in the
post-Holocene or that--
after the ice-- last
ice ages ended--
not post-Holocene but
after post-ice age
that we started building
this kind of civilization.
And it's only now
that we-- the planet
is starting to notice
that we're here.
And in order to deal
with the problem,
we're going to have
to start thinking
the way a planet thinks.
And what I want to
argue is we've only
learned how to do that
in the last 20 years
or so for a bunch of reasons.
So a little test, which
of these is the Earth?
AUDIENCE: Is it all of them?
Which--
ADAM FRANK: What?
AUDIENCE: Is it all of them?
ADAM FRANK: All of them.
Yeah, it's right.
That's exactly the question.
I mean-- oh, yeah, I'm always
glad when people see that,
right?
So the idea here is here's
six different Earths,
right, that this one is the
Earth in the Hadean right
after it formed.
It was a liquid magma ocean.
This is a version of the
Earth that was a water world.
It took a while for
the continents to grow.
So when you see those animations
of the continents sliding
all around, those only go back
a few hundred million years
or so, because in the
beginning all we had were
what were called
cratons that were--
it took a while for
the continents to grow.
So Earth was a water world.
There were periods
when the planet
has been so warm that it's
been virtually no ice anywhere
on it.
So we've been a jungle world.
There's been periods
when the Earth has
been a snowball basically
glaciated almost from top
to bottom or from
a pole to equator.
Here's the Earth we-- the
happy Earth we know now.
And here is the Earth--
actually not all that long.
In maybe another 2 billion years
or so that as the sun heats up
like any main
sequence star will do,
the temperature's going
to get high enough
to push the Earth outside
of the habitable zone.
So the point here is that the
Earth has worn many masks,
right?
And what's happening
with us now is we're
changing the mask that the
Earth is about to wear.
So we should get used to this.
And it should become
part of our story.
Now so as I said the Earth
has had worn many masks.
I love this diagram that a
friend of mine or a guy I knew
drew, just a beautiful
representation
of all the different
eras and epochs
and eons of the Earth's history.
And you see all of
the different times
and the different
kinds of animals.
But what's important is we're
up here in the Holocene, right?
And each of these
different Earths
represents wildly
different conditions
that the planet
has passed through.
But what we have been living
in, in the last 10,000
years, which geologically is
not that long, is the Holocene.
And here is a record
of temperature.
And there's zero.
This is variations from
the current average.
And here is ice content.
What you can see is the ice
has been going up and then
down, up and down.
And these periods
when the temperature
sort of pokes above zero
is-- these are interglacials.
So the Holocene, which
is the entire history
of human civilization, is
just the latest interglacial.
So the whole of human
civilization-- all our history,
all our wars and
hardship and creativity
has been in the Holocene.
But if you look at the
Earth's history overall--
and this is one
of the revolutions
I'm going to talk about that
we've undergone in the last 20
or 30 years that give us this
new perspective on what's
happening to us with
climate change--
you see how dramatically
life has played
a role in these transitions.
So what-- here's
another question.
These are the only two--
I promise-- the only
two test questions.
What would've happened if
you landed on the Earth
about three billion
years ago and walked out
of your spaceship?
What's the first thing
that would happen?
You'd suffocate, very good.
Because what's amazing-- even
though the Earth had lots
of life on it-- life had been on
the Earth for a billion years--
there was no oxygen in
the atmosphere, right?
The oxygen-- it was a pure,
a nitrogen CO2 atmosphere.
And most of the oxygen
got put in place
around 2.5 billion years ago
in what's called the Great
Oxidation Event.
So this is a plot of oxygen
concentration versus time.
And you can see the
oxygen content was
a million times less
than it is today back
then even though the
Earth was rich with life.
And what created the
Great Oxidation Event?
It was blue-green bacteria.
It was the invention of a new
kind of photosynthesis that
used water as a substrate and
burped out-- or farted out,
depending how you
want to look at it--
farted out oxygen, thereby
changing the atmosphere
of the entire
planet and changing
the entire evolutionary history,
the evolutionary trajectory
from that point on,
not just for life--
though it had huge
consequences, right?
You couldn't have big
brains that like we
have without the energy that
comes with oxygen metabolism,
but also for the planet itself.
By having all this
oxygen, it completely
changed the chemical cycles that
regulated the planet's history.
For example, it created ozone.
Without an ozone layer,
you could never--
without ozone you
would completely
change the dynamics
of the surface.
From the life's
perspective, without ozone
you could never
have colonized land.
So it was the step in
the Great Oxidation Event
that actually allowed
the land to be colonized.
So this is an example--
and it's something very
important for us now--
that life is constantly
coevolving with the planet,
right?
So in this plot, what
we see is on this side
is things that have happened
in Earth's history going back
four billion years
and things that have
happened in life's history.
And you see there's this
constant feedback between them
where the development of
a methane eating bacteria
will drive the great snowball
phases of the Earth's history.
Having oxygen allowed
sex actually to happen,
because it allowed organisms to
figure out sexual reproduction.
So life and planets coevolve.
That should be a lesson for
any life on any planet, right?
What we've seen is that the
biosphere is an important actor
in the history of our planet.
And we should expect
that it should
be a important actor in at least
other-- some other planets.
So this leads to what is called
the Gaia hypothesis, which
was controversial.
But let me tell you
a little about it.
It was proposed by
James Lovelock in 1979.
And the idea was that
all living things
on Earth kind of function
as a super organism
that that creates--
self-regulates the
planet for life,
right, that basically
even though the sun
is increasing in temperature,
the feedback loops
created by particularly
microorganisms
will regulate the
planet's temperature
to keep it cool even though the
overall solar radiation that's
hitting your planet is going up.
And this was actually an
incredibly important idea--
here is--
it was Lovelock and the
famous biologist Lynn
Margulis who got together and
sort of really built this.
And it was a very controversial
idea when it was first proposed
and part of that
because it became
kind of a New Age sort of--
there were Gaian churches.
And there were Gaian festivals.
It became a very
New Age woo idea.
And there was one
reason why scientists
didn't like it
though was because
of the idea of teleology.
It somehow seemed like it
implied like the Earth wanted
to go somewhere,
like the Earth had
a mind, that it was trying to
direct itself for some purpose.
And of course, we know that
evolution is blind, right?
But over time both
Margulis and Lovelock
were able to show that
there's no teleology here.
This is still blind evolution
but that these feedbacks do
in fact work.
And so what happened was people
kind of dropped the name Gaia.
And it became Earth
systems science.
We now don't talk about Gaia.
We talk about the
coupled Earth systems.
And by that we mean the
biosphere, the atmosphere,
the hydrosphere, which is all
the water, the cryosphere,
which ends up playing a
huge role-- all the ice--
and then the lithosphere.
So what we now understand is
that the Earth is this very
strongly coupled system.
Coupled systems--
they all interact.
And that life has been driving a
lot of this evolution for quite
a long time.
So that was really the
main result of Gaia
was to get scientists to
understand that life is not
some green scruff just
sitting on the surface
passively, that it hijacked
the planet a long time ago.
And when we think
astrobiologically,
this is a key idea
for us as we go
hunting for other biospheres.
So right now there's
an enormous amount
of work, some of it
going right on over
at MIT, developing
models of exo-biospheres.
And they're using
these kinds of ideas
as the fundamental way
we're going to detect life
on other planets.
We're going to look for
signatures of biospheres,
chemical signatures
of biospheres--
it's a very Gaian idea and
actually goes back to Lovelock
in 1963.
He actually proposed that idea.
So this leads us now to
the Anthropocene, right?
So now that we have
some background here
about life and
coevolution and planets,
we come back to ourselves,
which is our entry
into the Anthropocene.
So the idea of the
Anthropocene-- it was first
proposed by Crutzen
and Stoermer in 2002.
And they were thinking
in terms of strata.
They were actually proposing
that a million years from now,
you would be able to see the
Earth's entry or our presence
by a layer of strata
that would have
chemical or isotopic
signatures of our presence.
But even more than that
it was the recognition
that human beings now are the
principal drivers of changes
in those coupled
planetary systems, right?
And this has now been verified
in multiple ways, things
like we can--
it's human beings who move
around most of the phosphorous
on the planet.
Climate change is
an obvious example.
Land colonization--
there's many, many markers
you can find to show that
really it's human beings that
are driving how
this system behaves,
which means we're
pushing it, right?
So the climate--
or those coupled
systems, this non-linear
complex system, right,
now it's been sitting at
the bottom of a well, right,
in potential energy so to speak.
And now we've been rocking it
hard enough over the last 150
years that we're now--
it's starting to roll off
into some other state.
So the Anthropocene is
something that is happening.
And the question is
what are its outcomes.
And do its outcomes
include us, right?
So the entry into
the Anthropocene
raises profound new
questions about the nature
of human activity within the
coupled planetary systems.
And what I want to show is
how by taking this 10,000
light-year view of
this, we actually
gained a pretty powerful
new way of talking
about climate change.
One of these is--
I just had a New York Times
op-ed two days ago about this--
is that this is not
about saving the Earth.
The Earth is going
to be just fine,
thank you very much, right?
So this whole often
gets framed as like,
oh, climate change, we
have to save the planet.
But as I like to say,
you know, the planet
is not a little furry bunny.
That's one of the lessons
of understanding the Earth's
history.
There are five known
mass extinctions.
Each one opened up
new niches for species
to evolve including like
this little critter here
who's your ancestor, right?
This was a mammal
that was around
during the time
of the dinosaurs.
And it was only
the mass extinction
that allowed she and her
progenitors to lead to us.
So even though we're
driving a mass extinction
in terms of the long-term
history of the Earth,
the planet will just
use that for a new round
of evolutionary innovation.
So when we talk
about sustainability
what we have to be very careful
is to understand what are
we trying to sustain, right?
And what are the
moral imperatives
that we invoke for doing so?
So often, for example,
we show these pictures
of polar bears on
lonely ice floes
to drive some guilt and
some action hopefully.
But the idea is there--
when we think about this--
is that, oh, my god.
We can't let the polar
bears go extinct.
But on the other hand who's
crying for this guy, right?
The velociraptors
were once around.
And they went extinct.
Lots of species
have gone extinct.
So we need to understand
what exactly are we
trying to sustain.
Is it the polar bear for itself?
Or is it the sort of our
framing inside the biosphere?
Now I need to make
something very clear,
right, because at this point,
some people are getting
really angry at
me, like, well, you
don't care about polar bears.
I do care about
polar bears, right?
But the polar bears get fit
into this larger question,
which we're not asking.
So for sure climate
change is an immediate
and possibly existential threat
to the project of civilization.
It is imperative that
we act immediately
and with some force in
order to deal with this.
So nothing I'm saying
here takes that away.
But the problem is-- one problem
is why haven't we acted, right?
Why after years-- and
Johnson brought this up--
why haven't we acted?
And part of my argument
here is that we've
had-- the story
we've been telling us
has been able to be co-opted.
The main story
we've been telling
has been co-opted
by climate deniers
as a way of blunting
our activity.
So what are we
trying to sustain?
What we really are
trying to sustain
if we're being honest is the
climactic conditions that
are amenable to a particular
kind of civilization-- ours,
right?
It's technological.
It's energy intensive.
It's got a pretty
high population.
I mean, hopefully we can bring
the population slowly down.
But unless somebody wants to
volunteer to off themselves,
it's going to have a high
population for a while.
And also what we want is
maximum human well-being.
Actually what we want--
you can add to this maximum
biospheric well-being including
polar bears, right?
But we have to understand that
really what we're trying to do
is we're trying to hold some
version of the Holocene, right?
We are having a great preference
for the Holocene, right?
I mean we have to understand
why we're doing that.
We should be honest about
And as the Anthropocene goes
on, one of the things I'm saying
is what you're
going to be holding
is a version of the Holocene.
It's not the Holocene
anymore, because we're here.
And we're going to have impacts.
So by sustaining the
Holocene in perpetuity
we take on the role
of planetary stewards.
And what does that
actually mean?
What does that make us?
How do we fit into nature
in particular, right?
In some sense, the
view I'm advocating--
a city is no different from
a forest from the biospheres
perspective, right?
We are what the biosphere
is doing right now.
So and particularly
what is nature?
In a planet that has a
technological civilization
on it--
a large-scale energy intensive
technological civilization--
what is nature?
What counts as nature anymore?
So now I want to come to--
this will be the second
half of the talk--
the astrobiological perspective,
how actually thinking
about planets
generically, which is
what we should be doing, because
that's what we've learned
over the last 20 or 30 years--
how does this change--
how does this reframe everything
I've just been saying?
So astrobiology is a
relatively new field.
It's about thinking about
life in its planetary context.
what's happened here
and what might happen
elsewhere in a deeply
scientific and deeply
interdisciplinary kind of way.
So there's been
three revolutions
that have happened in
astrobiology that we
want to address.
So clearly astrobiology
right now has an n equals
1 problem, right?
We can only have
one example of life.
And you can say,
like, well, how do
you even have a field when you
only have one thing to study?
The thing is though that if
you take that point of view
you're missing some
amazing things that
have happened, right?
So it's a very data
rich field in the sense
of these three revolutions--
the discovery of exoplanets,
the exploration of
our own solar system,
and the unpacking Earth's
4.5 billion year history.
So very quickly let's sort
of look what those are.
So number 1, exoplanets--
so when I was a
graduate student there
were no other planets in the
universe except our own, right?
This question of
exoplanets dates back--
you can see the Greeks
arguing about it, right?
So Aristotle felt
that the Earth was
the only world of its kind
in the entire universe.
And other Greek thinkers,
the atomists in particular,
were very sure that the
universe was full of planets.
And all those planets had life.
You follow through history.
And you can see sort of people
switching back and forth.
By the 1900s it was
thought that planets
were very rare,
because the way they
thought planets
would form was that--
the only way you could
get it was two stars
passing close to each other and
getting gravitational extrusion
like taffy.
So those collisions
would be so rare
that it was thought
that planets--
one in a trillion stars
would have planets around it.
And so this went on
until 1995 we discovered
our first exoplanet, right?
It's not often that you
get to live at a time when
a 3,000-year-old question
gets definitively answered.
Since then something
remarkable has happened,
which is particularly
the Kepler mission, which
uses transits when you look
for the planet passing in front
of the star so the light dims
a little bit that now suddenly
we went from sort of a
retail planet hunting
to wholesale planet hunting.
And so now what
we know remarkably
is that every star-- pretty much
every star you see in the sky
has a family of
worlds around it,
I mean that is a remarkable.
Planets are everywhere
other than perhaps
the most massive stars which
themselves are very rare.
Every star has planets.
And if you count up five stars--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5--
one of them is going to have
a planet in the right place
for life to form.
It will be what's called
the habitable zone where
liquid water can form.
And we think water is
essential for life.
So one out of every five is
in the right place for life
to form.
So that was one revolution.
The other revolution
was we've sent robots--
robot emissaries now,
robot ambassadors--
to pretty much
every kind of body
in the solar system--
asteroids, comets.
We've visited every planet
in the solar system.
We've had rovers rolling
around at least one of them.
But we've had stuff touch
down on a lot of others.
And so we get pictures like
this, which could be Mars.
Or it could be the
Mojave Desert--
turns out it's Mars, right?
But this has been
decades now that we've
been rolling around on Mars.
And we've learned
amazing things.
For example, we
now know for sure
that Mars was a blue world.
In the early part of the
solar system Mars most likely
looked like this.
It was had a much
thicker atmosphere.
It had water-- at least
lakes if not oceans on it.
There is strata that we can see
that you can do the estimate
to show that water
probably hip-deep
was rushing at about 3 feet
per second across that channel.
So it's remarkable.
So it shows us, especially
in dealing with climate,
is to show people that
it's not like we just
have the Earth to study
when it comes to climate.
We have tested our climate
models against Mars,
against Venus, against Titan.
And with those models all--
I can predict the
weather on Mars
basically tomorrow with
great accuracy, right?
So the idea that these
climate models are just
kind of oh, something
somebody made up,
that's just completely wrong.
We know how climate
works, because we've
seen how climate works now on
six different kinds of planets,
all very different.
So our study of the
solar system has--
that's what's taught us
to think like a planet
or at least taught us how
without life, right?
And then through
the Earth study,
we're able to think
like a planet with life.
What's also important is
to show that sustainability
is-- just like
habitability-- is probably
going to be a moving target.
We're going have to
learn to think that way,
because the Mars
used to be habitable.
But it certainly isn't
now except for maybe just
very extremophile
kinds of creatures.
So that was revolution number 2.
And then revolution number
3 as I kind of already
went through is the unpacking
of Earth's history--
the Great Oxidation
Event, the thermal maxima
that have occurred when
the planet was a jungle
world, the Snowball Earth.
We now really have seen
that Earth is so many
different-- has been so
many different planets
that in some sense it gives
us all those different eras.
It's almost like we've got nine
different planets with life
to study by studying
the Earth's history,
because they were so different.
So where does all this lead us?
Well, by using the
astrobiological perspective,
we can think about the
Anthropocene in a broader
context.
And then this question comes up,
right, which nobody ever asks.
We all know that we
have to build a system
version of civilization.
But how do we know that's
even possible, right?
How do we know that's
something the universe does?
Universe has--
makes black holes.
Universe makes comets.
Universe makes
interstellar clouds of gas.
How do we know it makes
long-term sustainable versions
of energy-intensive
civilizations,
right, because it may
be that there's just
no such thing like
that in the universe.
So this-- by framing it
this way, suddenly we're
going to ask the questions
in a very different way.
But of course obviously it
means taking exo-civilizations
seriously, right?
And I'm using exo-civilizations
rather than aliens
for a particular reason, right?
So now when I say this, I'm
not talking about detection.
I'm not talking about
going out and finding them,
though that is definitely
an interesting thing,
particularly in the era
that we're in when we
have all these new exoplanets.
I'm not talking about the
details of their biology--
whether they look like
reptiles, whether they
have nine fingers on each hand,
what kind of sex they have.
That's not amenable.
I don't have any
constraints scientifically
to actually address that.
And certainly not sociology--
are they communist, capitalist,
peace-loving, not--
there's just nothing
I can do there.
What I can do,
however, is I can focus
on the co-evolution
of civilization
and a coupled planetary
systems in a scientific way.
I now know enough to run
models of this interaction
and ask what the generic
response of a planet
is when it's got an energy
intensive civilization.
And that's what I'm
going to convince--
I'm going to show you a
little bit of those results.
We've run those models,
just actually published
them just a little while ago.
All right.
So my emphasis
here is it's really
time to start doing this,
because it matters for us.
And that means it's time to take
exo-civilizations seriously.
And it's time to stop
snickering about it, right,
because any time you try and
bring up aliens it's always
like pffft, aliens, he he he.
And that was a long time in
the scientific community.
And it's because of
prosthetic foreheads, right?
The reasons we can't
talk about aliens
seriously is because we've had
years of bad television science
fiction where everybody
looks like us.
But they've got
maybe antenna on us.
So we're in a different
universe now, right?
We recognize the
civilization that we've built
is the kind of
alien civilization
we've always been dreaming
of on a certain level, right?
So we need now to get past
the snicker factor and ask,
because that's our own--
it's related to our own
survival in some sense.
So what I'm going to tell
you now for the next 10,
15 minutes is
we're going to head
towards a science of
exo-civilizations, theoretical
studies that are relevant
to the Anthropocene.
So first of all, we
have to recognize
when we think about
exo-civilizations it's always
been a battle between
optimists and pessimists,
right, if you look at the
history of this field.
And what I'm going to argue
is that changes significantly
with the new data.
So I'm sure many of you
are familiar with the Drake
equation, right?
So long interesting history--
the Drake equation
was basically a way
of figuring out how many
civilizations exist right now
that we could communicate with.
And they did that by
breaking up the problem
into a bunch of
different pieces--
the number of stars in
the galaxy, the fraction
of those stars
that have planets,
the number of those planets
in the habitable zone,
the fraction of those
planets that form life,
the fraction of that
life that goes on
to intelligence, the fraction of
that intelligence that develops
technology, and finally,
as I like to call it,
the final factor--
bum bum bum-- the
average lifetime.
That's actually the thing
we're really interested in.
What is the average lifetime
of a civilization like ours?
So I won't go into
this in detail.
But in a paper that we
did in a couple of years
ago Woody Sullivan and I
used the Kepler data, right?
We've got all this
data about planets
now, which we
didn't have before.
And we used it to sort
of figure out, well,
what can you say about
exo-civilizations empirically
based on all this new data.
And what we found is that if
you ask the right question,
you could say something
pretty remarkable.
So here's what we ca--
we defined something
we called the pessimism line.
And it answers the
following question.
What does the probability
for a civilization evolving
on a random planet
have to be for humanity
to be the only time
it's ever happened?
What's the limit on that
probability from this new data
that we've gotten so that we're
the only time that civilization
has ever happened?
And we can do this now.
We can set an empirical limit
on this, because we now know--
if I go back, right, when
Drake wrote down this equation,
that was the only
term that was known.
Now these two terms
have been nailed.
So that's a pretty large
increase in your understanding
for this equation.
There's only seven terms in it.
So it turns out for us to be
the only time in cosmic history
that a civilization has
arisen the probability would
have to be 10 to the
minus 22 or lower.
1 in 10 billion trillion.
If the probability for forming
a civilization on a planet--
nature is going to
set this, right,
through its
evolutionary process.
If it's any larger than this
number, it's happened before.
That's a pretty small number.
You don't have to work very
hard in order to get higher
than 1 in 10 billion trillion.
As long as it's bigger than
that, we're not the first time
there's been a
technological civilization.
So what that means-- so if you
look at like famous pessimists
in time--
Ernst Mayr or Brandon Carter--
I won't go through this--
these are people who are like,
no, civilizations are
really hard to make.
They never happen.
They're really rare.
Their numbers are so much
larger than that pessimism line
that there's has
been tens of millions
or trillions of civilizations
over cosmic space and time.
And the reason why it
was important to do
this it was because
what we're really asking
is if you had a statistical
ensemble of alien civilizations
what would their
history be, right?
They're all going to go through
what we're going through.
That's part of the
argument is that it's hard
not to trigger an Anthropocene,
because a civilization is just
a way of taking energy,
harvesting energy
from your planet and doing work.
Second law of
thermodynamics is kind
of going to demand that you
have some kind of feedback.
So what this work shows is
that it's really not hard--
you don't have to work very hard
in terms of the probabilities
to end up with the
conclusion that there's
been lots of histories.
And so doing--
thinking statistically
about Anthropocenes
is not a bad idea.
So the Anthropocene-- it's
happened before probably,
right, which is a
remarkable thing.
So that's what this
idea that like we
look at what's
happening with Earth
and we have this huge
political debate.
Everybody's freaking
out, because it's
as if like we're a
teenager who is going
through our emotional stuff.
And we kind of feel
like nobody's ever
gone through this before.
And then they talk.
They get to an encounter
group or something.
And they talk to others.
They realize, oh, everybody's
gone through this before.
So by modeling this
what can we figure out?
So the claim is we know
enough about planets
and how they
respond to forcing--
meaning thermodynamic
driving-- to begin modeling
how any species will drive
feedbacks on their planet
through energy harvesting
and civilization building.
So this is my call--
[LAUGHS]
--with tongue held
lightly in cheek
the theoretical archeology
of exo-civilizations.
So how do we do this?
Well, what we're
going to do is we're
going to do dynamical
systems modeling.
We're going to set up equations
for a population interacting
with its environment.
And this is a
time-honored process
in population biology
going all the way back
to the predator-prey
model where you basically
have an equation for
the bunnies, an equation
for the wolves.
And they're coupled,
right, because when
the wolves eat the bunnies
they get more wolf babies.
But too many wolf babies and
there's no bunnies left to eat.
So you can write
down these equations,
solve them and you find
these oscillations that are
out-of-phase beautifully--
the data really match
this really well.
So population
biology-- you don't
have to assume a lot about
population biology other
than you eat more resources,
you get more babies.
That's the only assumption
I'm making in the models
that we're making.
And maybe you can
say, OK, well, maybe
on life on another
planet doesn't do that.
But that seems kind
of fundamental to what
we think of as life.
So when we thought
about doing this
what we imagine is
we'd have some phase
space of planetary
parameters, right,
like energy
consumption, population,
feedback on the planet.
And what we imagine
is when we ran
the models we'd get
different kinds of solutions.
So you can imagine you start
off with a very low population.
And you're not using a
lot of energy per person.
And what happens is as time goes
on, your technology increases.
You start using more energy.
Your population goes up.
You make more babies.
But eventually at some point
you're using so much energy.
You're feeding
back on the planet.
And your-- the trajectory
of your population
will end up heading
in this direction.
And it gets too large.
And perhaps the planet responds.
You start having instabilities,
wild climate changes.
And then your population
would come way back down.
You'd basically collapse, right?
That's a collapse trajectory.
Or you could have a
sustainability trajectory
where you figure out
how to deal with this.
And you end up with some
nice steady state where
your population is stable and
your feedback on the planet
is stable.
So this is what we were looking
to do when we built our models.
And it's very interesting to
look at the Earth right now.
This is the world
energy consumption
from 10,000 BC to now.
So that's our energy per capita.
This is CO2 concentration,
which is the planetary forcing.
And this is global population.
So those are those three
parameters for the Earth.
And you see that,
yeah, like we're
pretty much on a
trajectory for something--
enormous increase, exponential
increase in world population,
energy use, and the
feedback on the planet.
So what happens
next generically?
So what we did is--
these models-- actually the
paper just came out recently.
I won't go into the
equations that we used.
These were actually--
these were,
as you guys all understand,
a toy model, right?
We tried to capture the
essentials of the interaction
between a population using
a planetary resource,
making more babies but having
that planetary resource feed
back on the state of the planet.
So that you end up--
the planet drifts
away from where
it was when you were
born as a civilization.
So here's what the
solutions look like.
So in these plots green is the
population of the civilization.
And red you can think of
as planetary temperature.
And what we found broadly
even in these simple models
were three classes
of trajectory.
First was what we
called die off.
So here you see the die off.
The population
rises very quickly,
because it's consuming
the planet's resource.
The planet heats up.
The conditions on
the planet change.
But then the population
overshoots the planet's
carrying capacity-- how
many of that organism
the planet can sustain.
And then you get a big drop in
the number of the population
until you come to some
kind of nice steady state.
But you do it at some cost.
So you can lose in our models
up to 70% of your population.
So imagine that everybody
you knew, 7 out of every 10
people you knew
disappeared because
of climate-related disasters.
So it's not clear
that a civilization
could survive that.
Maybe it could.
But at least the
good news here was
you did get a steady
state in the end.
There was also what we called
sustainable or soft landing.
That was the really good news.
Yeah, there's
definitely solutions
where you change the planet--
red-- the temperature goes up.
Your population goes up.
And your energy use goes up.
But you come to
some steady state.
So the models admitted
that kind of solution.
But there was also the
possibility of collapse.
And there's enough in
there to be worrisome
where the population rises.
The planet goes into
a runaway essentially,
just like Venus
went into a runaway
with a runaway
greenhouse effect,
why Venus' temperature
is now 800 degrees.
So this is a different
kind of runaway
but the same basic idea.
And your population comes all
the way down to extinction.
Now whether or not you
actually are extinct,
what really matters
is you can't maintain
your technological, highly
coupled networked civilization
anymore.
So that's in some sense
what collapse means.
But also interesting we found
these oscillations as well
in there.
The population rises and then
falls and rises and falls.
But either way so these
were simple models.
But they gave us a hint that
there are generic classes
of behavior in the models.
So this leads us to
eventually-- so this
was a first cut at this.
What the next step
is we're going
to build in real climate models.
We're going to build in the
response of different kinds
of energy sources, right?
There's only going to be so
many kinds of energy sources
a planet gives a
young civilization.
You're going to have combustion,
maybe not fossil fuels.
But if there's biomass,
you can burn it--
wind, solar, et cetera.
So we can build that
into these and really
have much more physically
accurate kinds of models.
And then we can run it for
all kinds of planets-- planets
that are close to the inner edge
of the habitable zone, planets
that are further out, planets
that start with oxygen,
planets that start
with less oxygen.
We can do all different
kinds of things.
And from that what we're
going to get is a predict--
we're going to make a prediction
for this average lifetime.
Now this really matters for us,
because if the average lifetime
of a civilization
is 200 years, we're
hosed, right,
because what it means
is there's very
little wiggle room.
You don't have a lot of leeway
in the bets you make as you try
and navigate your Anthropocene.
Almost nobody makes it, right?
On the other hand, if
your average lifetime
is two million years, yeah,
then you can make mistakes.
There's a lot of-- you can
experiment and still make it
through.
Lots of civilizations
managed to make it
through their Anthropocenes.
So this is the thing that
we're headed towards seeing.
And this itself sort of frames
what's happening to us now
in this sense that we are one
species out of many species
that have gone through this.
And we sort of need
to think more broadly
about our choices in that case.
So more to the point
and because we're
almost done here the
astrobiological perspective--
what it tells us is that
energy-harvesting species
and their civilizations
are simply something
that planets do.
We can't keep
thinking of ourselves
as somehow special or unique.
We are what the biosphere
is doing now, right?
The biosphere runs experiments.
Planets with biospheres run
experiments over and over
again.
And we are simply
one of those, right?
Human beings and
our civilization--
we're just part of nature.
The biosphere has done
lots of interesting things.
It invented grasslands.
That was a new
idea at one point.
And then the grasslands spread
across the planet, changed
the planet's functioning.
It invented dinosaurs.
It invented blue-green bacteria.
We are just what the
biosphere has invented
and is playing with now.
And there's no reason
to think that we're
going to be what happens later.
So we're an expression
of the planet now.
But do we continue to be an
expression of the planet?
So one of these things, right--
so this is very controversial.
I can get people really get
pissed off at me for this.
What this means is climate
change is not our fault.
One of the things I want
to push us away from
is this narrative we
have of that human beings
are a plague on the planet.
We suck, right?
When it comes to
climate change, we
don't have many stories,
right, many sort
of species-wide,
planetary-wide stories
about ourselves, because as I
said, it's a new transition.
And the only story
we have either is
it's not happening
at all, which is
what you get from the climate
denialists or we're terrible.
We're horrible.
We're a virus on the planet.
And what I'm pointing out
here is that that's not true.
So what do I mean by
this before anybody
gets really angry with me?
What I mean is that civilization
since its beginning has done
what?
It has always looked
for energy sources
that it can power its buildings,
right, its irrigation.
And we've been doing this since
the end of the Holocene, right?
So when we found oil it wasn't
like we were like mwahahahaha.
I will destroy the planet
with this substance.
It was like, oh,
there's this brown goo.
And it's awesome.
You can heat your home.
You can build internal
combustion engines.
It was great stuff.
We didn't know we were going
to trigger climate, right?
It was an unintended
consequence of the adoption
of a particular energy
modality, right?
But now that we know if
we don't do anything,
right, now not doing anything
about it would be our fault.
It would be our failure.
It would be our folly.
It would be why we end up in the
garbage heap of civilizations
that couldn't manage their
transition to maturity.
So this doesn't absolve us
some of the responsibility
of doing something about it
given how important it is.
So what I'm trying
to do here really
is change the narrative, right?
The Anthropocene is not a
story of inherent human greed.
It is not a story of our
unworthiness on the planet,
that the planet's trying to
get rid of us in some sense.
It's not a story of us as
being a plague on the planet.
Instead the Anthropocene
is a story--
and that we're
just waking up to--
about planets and their
experiments, right?
We didn't know about
Earth's 4.5 billion
year history of
life and coevolution
until very recently.
That is a new
story for humanity.
And now we have to recognize
is how we fit into this, right,
both because it's
true and also it's
the story we need to understand
to make it through the climate
change we've triggered.
So for me the true lesson--
so "Childhood's End"--
any science fiction fans,
right, one of the great science
fiction books.
The true lessons
of the Anthropocene
are that planets have rules.
And we need to
learn them, right?
Planets are machines, right?
And we need to understand
how they function in order
to put ourselves back
into them, right?
Sustainability is
really in some sense
an awakened planet in
which both the biosphere
and the civilization can
flourish in entirely new ways.
This is a paper
we wrote recently
where we looked at what would
be the thermodynamic properties
of a planet with a large-scale
civilization on it.
And the conclusions we came
to-- there's got to be some kind
of cooperative relationship
where the civilization makes
the biosphere even
more productive,
not just for itself but for--
not for the civilization's end
but for the biosphere's end.
And it's really-- and
this is about the adoption
of what has been called
deep ecological values where
compassion and the
identification with life,
because yeah, we're
part of the biosphere.
We're not above it--
is a kind of primary value.
And this is what's
interesting for me.
It's actually the
completion of Gaia, right?
Remember when I talked about one
of the big scientific pushbacks
on the Gaia hypothesis was
that it was teleological.
It had meaning.
It had a direction, right?
And we know that
evolution is blind.
Yeah, it's blind until
something like us shows up.
Once you get a
technological civilization
you're no longer blind, right?
The evolution is
no longer blind.
We bring meaning.
We bring direction now to
the evolution of the planet.
So there's this idea that goes
way back of the noosphere.
I don't know if anybody
ever heard of this.
So there were two
versions of this.
Teilhard de Chardin, which he
was a little bit more mystical.
He was a scientist
and a Jesuit as well.
And he sort of thought
of it as the world
being enshrouded in thought
or in the world's soul.
But there was also Verdansky,
Vladamir Verdansky,
the great geochemist's
idea, which was more like,
yeah, once thought
appears on the planet
now just like
there's a biosphere,
there's going to be a
sphere of thought around it.
And the interesting thing
was de Chardin's version
of this, of the world
being covered in thought,
the more mystical
one was the one
that most people know about.
But of course, what happened
is by-- and this is the great
place to talk about this--
we ended up building
a noosphere, right?
I mean, by mistake--
we didn't know we
were going to make a noosphere.
But like right now
this room is full
of electromagnetic radiations
carrying thought, right?
I mean everybody's cell phone
is picking up on the noosphere.
So the idea of there
being a directionality
to the biosphere's
evolution once
a technological civilization
shows up may actually be--
now that the world is covered
in the noosphere, right?
So these are the internet
links across the planet.
That may actually be a
natural part of the evolution.
So with all of this
for me actually leads--
it's a story of hope, right?
So I did an Atlantic
story about those--
the study we did of the
different possibilities
of interaction between a planet
and a civilization, right?
And all the stor--
I did an Atlantic story on it.
And it got picked up.
And everybody was focusing
on all the trajectories
that led to death and disaster.
And I had to be like,
whoa, wait a minute.
One of the trajectories
was sustainability.
So like even those simple
models point out to the fact,
like, yeah, you can do this.
I mean from that
simple perspective--
if the question is is
sustainability possible,
the answer is yes.
It may be hard to achieve.
But at least it exists according
to those very simple models,
right?
So I'm hopeful.
So in its context--
in the cosmic context
in some sense,
the Anthropocene doesn't--
it's not a story with villains
in it, right?
As much as I am very angry at
the people who promote climate
denial, they're not villains.
They're folly.
They are the agent
of our folly that
will lead us to not
reaching our own potential.
But from the
biosphere's perspective
planets have histories.
They have trajectories.
And hopefully you can manage
to get yourself on a good one
and vote out the people who
are keeping you holding back.
So it's a story about
winners and losers.
And essentially
what I want to say
is that we are cosmic teenagers
and that we need to grow up.
So I think someone has done it.
So why can't we?
And I'll end with this.
This is a picture.
Bill Nye came to the
University of Rochester.
And he gave a talk.
And I was ama-- i
mean, I knew Bill Nye
when I was a graduate
student in Seattle.
But I didn't realize how much
the student-- how much the love
the students had for him.
And he was there talking
about climate change
and how students can
solve climate change.
And these guys were all there.
And they were like, yeah!
I never saw so much
optimism and hope.
So like I absolutely think
this is a solvable problem.
But we have the wrong story.
And until we change that story
we're going to kind of be--
our options will be limited.
So I thank you very much.
I really appreciate
your time and listening.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know if anybody
wants to ask questions.
But-- yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
one part of one slide.
Sorry.
Possibility of civilization once
you're in the habitable zone,
I believe, was 10
to the negative 22.
ADAM FRANK: Not the
possibility that if--
we don't know what the
actual probability is, right?
AUDIENCE: True, true.
This is the--
ADAM FRANK: Right.
The limit the pessimism limit.
If it's below that,
then we're the only time
it's ever happened.
If nature's choice for that
probability is above that,
then there's been lots.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if
though if you could expand--
you basically said, well,
that's a really small number.
ADAM FRANK: Right.
AUDIENCE: At an absolute
value, it's very small.
ADAM FRANK: Right.
AUDIENCE: So therefore I'm
going to bet that it's larger.
ADAM FRANK: Right.
AUDIENCE: That doesn't
seem very satisfying to me.
There are lots of
numbers in nature
that turn out to
actually be very small--
ADAM FRANK: Right.
AUDIENCE: Smaller than
humans would have guessed.
ADAM FRANK: Right
AUDIENCE: So there
was a turnout it
would be hugely bigger than
humans would have guessed,
because we tend to anchor
on numbers around one.
ADAM FRANK: Right.
AUDIENCE: So can you help--
ADAM FRANK: Yes, no,
that's a good point.
So that's why the
history of this debate
is important, right?
That number doesn't
appear out of nowhere.
I mean-- it comes from--
that number doesn't appear
out of context, right?
So there have been
over the years,
over 50 years people
trying to approximate,
do some kind of
calculation that shows them
what this probability should be.
And the best of them all is
what's called the hard step
model by Brandon Carter.
And that's in-- the
hard step model has now
become you know actually
essential, because you
could actually calculate
probabilities out of it.
And what he did--
it's typical brilliant reasoning
where he just basically--
he looked at the history
of the Earth and said, oh,
look the Earth is only going
to be habitable for another
billion or half--
maybe a half billion years.
And intelligence didn't show
up until the end, right?
So therefore it must
be-- intelligence
must be hard, right?
And so then he came
up with this idea
there must have been
a bunch of hard steps
that evolution
had to go through.
So from that he was able to
use the correct probability
distributions, et cetera.
And he estimated there
were 10 hard steps, right?
And so then he calculated out of
that what that probability had
to be there for.
And he got 10 to the 20.
And he concluded in
that-- there's actually--
I put that quote in there.
I'd have to switch
all the way back.
But he basically said, based
on this 10 to the minus 20.
Sorry.
He said, based on this,
we are the only time
that civilization
has ever formed
in the history of the universe.
Now you do the--
you've got data.
You put it in.
You find that no,
actually, in your model--
in Brandon Carter's
model there's
a hundred civilizations
that have occurred
across cosmic history, right?
And we now know that there--
not know-- but now the idea is
there's not 10 hard steps.
There's maybe only
five hard steps.
Now again this is all
still controversial.
We don't even know if the
hard step model is true.
But it's the best one
that we have that actually
gives us-- allows us to
do something or articulate
something numerically.
And with five hard steps you're
down to 10 to the minus 15,
which means there would have
been 10 million civilizations
over cosmic space and time.
So when you look at
the history and what--
almost no pessimist historically
has gone that far down.
So if they were right,
there would still
have been lots of civilizations.
So I hope that helps
AUDIENCE: It does.
ADAM FRANK: Yeah, I mean
it's still of course,
we are in the realm until we
actually find one you're going
to be dealing with--but
the best science we have--
the history of this
field-- people--
the best estimations makes
that number very, very small.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I've also been
watching too much Sci-Fi
lately.
[LAUGHS]
ADAM FRANK: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
watching "The Expanse" a lot.
[GASPS]
ADAM FRANK: Fav.
Best show ever, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
the chances of humans actually
getting to a full
solar system-wide--
Or--
ADAM FRANK: What I argue
often is that's the prize.
If we make it through
climate change,
that's what's waiting for us.
I mean, I really do believe--
interstellar travel-- I'm
actually right now writing
a paper about the
Fermi paradox--
interstellar travel may
be very, very difficult.
But interplanetary
travel, especially
if you have some kind of
fusion engine will not be.
And I think in another 200
years-- like, who knows, right?
There are obviously very
formidable problems.
But I am hopeful.
I'm a techno-optimist.
And I'm hopeful that
in 200, 300 years there
can be a lot of people--
that the solar system has
a lot of nooks and crannies
that human beings can--
and people say, well,
why would they do that?
Because basically
everybody wants
to create their own society.
What I love "The
Expanse" gets right--
there's going to be
Mormons in space.
For sure, so they can create
their own space settlement
and live Mormon life.
And there'll be 1,000
versions of that.
So I think, yeah, if we can
just figure out climate change.
And they're related,
right, because you're not
going to be able to-- in
order to solve climate change,
you have to think like a planet.
But in order to have a
self-sustaining whatever bubble
civilization with a
million people in it,
you also have to understand
how planets think
and build a smaller
version of it.
That's why "The Expanse"
gets so well in the scene
after after Call--
what is it, Callisto?
Or Ganymede-- after the
station of Ganymede collapses
and what's-his-name [? Pac ?]
recognizes that, oh, my god.
The whole ecological
infrastructure of the thing
is going to collapse now.
Is anybody watching
"The Expanse?"
Are people watching
It's really good.
I really got-- and the
books are super awesome too.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you alluded
to it in a previous answer.
But I'm curious what
your thoughts are
about the Fermi paradox and--
ADAM FRANK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --the
theory [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM FRANK: Well first
of all, I want to--
there's two ways to think
about the Fermi paradox.
The first one is the idea
that we haven't found anybody.
We've been searching
the stars for signals.
And we haven't found anything.
And that's just not true.
I mean there's never really
been a large-scale SETI
effort, right?
SETI's never been
really fully funded.
NASA started to do
a large SETI search.
And then-- because William
Proxmire had stopped it.
So as Jill Tarter
says, if the parameter
space we have to search
for looking for aliens
is the ocean, we have
looked at a thimble so far.
So saying that we haven't
found anything that's
just not scientifically valid.
So we've barely begun to look,
not just in radio but all
the other possibilities.
But if you're asking about
the part of the Fermi paradox
that's why haven't we been
visited, like why don't we
have evidence for a
civilization, the colonization
part, that actually we find in
our paper is more of a problem.
And so the solution to
that right now in the paper
I think we're leaning towards
is that interstellar travel's
really hard.
You don't get many successful
colonization missions.
Obviously there's some
assumptions here in this.
But again we just did a
paper recently where--
I did it with Gavin Schmidt
from Goddard Institute
of Space Studies
where we just asked,
how would you-- this was an
amazing question-- how would
you know whether there was
a previous technological
civilization on Earth
20 million years ago?
You actually couldn't, right?
There is really-- and there
would not be much left over.
There would certainly
after-- by 20 million years
the surface has been
completely rescoured.
So you're not going
to find ruins.
Or you'd have to look
for isotopic anomalies
or something, which maybe--
AUDIENCE: Monuments on the moon.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM FRANK: Well,
that's the thing.
No, no, he's right actually.
That is exactly what
you'd have to look for.
So when it comes to
just the Earth itself,
the Earth has been
weathered so heavily
and subducted that
it would be hard.
And so there's been
a couple papers
on exactly that
about the best place
to look for this is going
to be on other bodies.
So-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So kind
of related to that,
I think of-- seems to be the one
part where you really do have
the n equals 1 problem is
what you were talking about--
the noosphere, right, because
you have all this evidence
for what happened
previously on Earth,
because we have
all these other--
ADAM FRANK: Right
AUDIENCE: --planets out there.
But a lot of this stuff,
especially with the Fermi
paradox, it seems to
me falls prey to this n
equals 1 problem.
We are sort of assuming
the intelligent--
or the civilization is going
to behave like we expect.
ADAM FRANK: I think that's
what my models tried
to have no sociology in them.
It's ba-- the only assumption
was a civilization consumes
energy to do work.
That's like the only
assumption in there.
So I don't need a
noosphere or anything else.
It's just that--
AUDIENCE: Did you
make assumptions
about what sort of
energy production?
ADAM FRANK: There's only so
much kind of energy production
you're going to get as a
young civilization, right?
The planet is only
going to afford you--
if you have z-rays, some like
super hyper, high technology,
well then you're already
passed this anyway, right?
If you have warp drives,
you're not really worrying
about your--
you've probably gotten-- your
science is so far advanced
that you probably have
already gone through this.
But if you're a young
civilization like ours,
you've got biomass.
Or you've got-- you
can burn things.
There's wind.
There's solar.
There's nuclear.
And there is geothermal, right?
And that's pretty much it.
It's-- you can't-- maybe on
some weird planet you could have
like super magnetic
fields or something.
So what you can do for
each one of those--
you can evaluate what
the thermodynamic effect
of using it large-scale.
So for example, there was a
paper done a few years ago
where they looked
at trying to extract
from wind energy the power--
what would the
consequences be of powering
our civilization via wind?
And what you find is because
of turbulence downstream,
you end up with the equivalent
of like two degrees of warming
so which is important
because what it means
is you can't power civilization
like this and have no impact.
So this goes back
to nature, right,
the idea that
there's going to be--
we're going to be able to
return to pristine nature--
not with us on
the planet, right?
You can have lower impact that
you're going to have to be.
You're going to have to figure
out what kind of impacts.
But the idea that you can
have no impact is just--
doesn't make sense.
So yeah, you can evaluate
for every different kind
of energy source at least make
a cut at what the impact would
be.
AUDIENCE: So then one more--
the assumption you're
making is that civilization
requires energy.
That seems to be
that something that I
think a lot of have--
that seems to be a very
commonist way of doing this.
ADAM FRANK: Well, I don't see--
I mean by-- in some
sense by definition,
an industrial civilization--
I mean, Rome-- I'm not
interested in Rome, right,
because Rome wouldn't Rome
wouldn't push its planet
into an Anthropocene, right?
So if a civilization decides
to get up to Rome's level
and never gets farther, yeah,
that's sort of out of the--
so you're right.
That's not what
I'm talking about.
But if you build an industrial
civil-- if you start har--
it's all about the
energy per capita, right?
So right now all of us
have the equivalent of just
from our home-- when we go
home in our plugs 50 servants.
That's the energy
equivalent of 50 servants.
And that doesn't say anything
about your transportation
or whatever.
So once the species
gets to the point
where the per capita
energy use becomes
more than one individual's
worth per individual,
that's when you're going
to start feeding back.
So that's the only assumption.
If they start doing
that, then they sort of
fall into the category
that I'm interested in.
And then I don't really
care about sociology
or whether they develop
a noosphere or not.
Maybe they do.
Maybe they don't.
It's just that they're
harvesting energy
to do the work of building
their civilization.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So do you think
that the current problem we're
facing is a matter of marketing,
that we have the tools
and sort of the guidance that
we need to get through if we all
just somehow banded together?
ADAM FRANK: Yeah,
I think that's--
I was just reading
recently about a study
that sort of showed--
a super detailed
study-- that you could
actually power the world with
renewables, with wind, water.
But so it was a really
detailed plan for doing it.
Of course, it required
this sort of World War II
Manhattan-style project
for the entire world.
And so that's going to be hard.
But in terms of like
technologically-- man,
unleash the innovation.
Let us-- that's one of those--
when I go out and I'm
talking to people,
one of the things I'm saying
is like, on one level,
climate change shows how
awesome we are, right?
I mean, as-- we've changed the
atmosphere of an entire planet.
That's pretty good for a
bunch of hairless monkeys.
And now the question
is are we smart enough
to innovate our
way into some kind
of sustainable version of this.
So it's-- it's not
just marketing though.
It's deeper than that.
It's myth, right?
Human beings always
need stories.
As somebody said, stories
were the first technology.
And the problem is
here we have all
of these-- from the long
history of humanity--
we have these myths about the
coming of age, about marriage,
about old age.
But we don't have any--
and we have creation myths.
But climate change we don't have
a myth for, because it's new.
We've never done this before.
And so what I'm
suggesting is, is
that a first--
it's not like this
alone is going to
solve anything.
But if we don't
change the narrative,
we are stuck arguing with
people about whether we
change the climate or not.
From this perspective that
question just disappears.
It's like, of course,
you changed the climate.
You built a civilization
that consumes
a quarter of the
entire biosphere's
productive capacity.
What did you expect?
So I think it just--
one of things in revolutions--
in scientific revolutions--
that happen is that
the old questions--
when you go through
a paradigm shift--
it's not that the old
questions are answered.
The old questions just don't
even become meaningful anymore.
People ask a new
set of questions.
And that's at least what
I'm proposing with this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This might
tread a little bit more
philosophical although
there are clearly
philosophical ideas that--
ADAM FRANK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: you put up there too.
You mentioned that
you're an optimist.
And piggybacking on the question
about marketing I sort of--
my worry is that
there is not, in fact,
at present in human
thinking the idea
that humanity is, in
fact, a single species.
ADAM FRANK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We can sort of
think about this as a collab--
as a truly
collaborative project.
And I think one way to
be pessimistic about this
is to worry about factional--
ADAM FRANK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Factionalization
and whatnot.
Do you have thoughts that make
you more optimistic on that?
Is it sort of-- and I'm not
saying that blind faith would
be unreasonable.
Perhaps--
ADAM FRANK: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: There's another
way to think about this.
ADAM FRANK: Yeah, oh, I mean
it's gotten us through a lot,
right?
But no, actually so I think
when you look across species,
I feel confident in my
bones that there have been
other civilizations, right?
Scientifically I can only
go far as the probabilities
that this has happened before.
And what I imagine
is the ones that
make it have either the
evolutionary background
to have the right kinds of
behaviors-- maybe hive mind.
It's much easier if
you're a hive mind
to make it through this than
if you're the kind of thing
that we are.
But the other possibility is
that you evolve under pressure,
right?
Selective pressure is
what determines evolution.
And perhaps this is
the agent by which we
start to create new behaviors.
Sure, the Paris Accord was weak.
But the Paris Accord was
also remarkable in the sense
that we've got every
country to sign this thing.
So that was a beginning.
And then we took
a giant step back.
But so I think--
the Anthropocenes
may be the agent
for some kinds of species,
perhaps like ours,
to develop new
evolutionary behaviors that
allow them to get through.
And if you make it through--
it's weird.
Like if I put my hat on as
a dad, I'm like, oh, my god.
We've got to make it through.
[LAUGHS]
But if I put my hat on as
an astronomer I'm like,
eh, some make it through.
Some don't.
AUDIENCE: Nothing
special about us.
ADAM FRANK: Yeah,
nothing special about us.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
I really appreciate
you guys coming today.
[APPLAUSE]